[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
régionales et locales de la tnt et sur
tv5 monde avec la participation de la
presse quotidienne régionale
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité de cette édition
et si c'était larmes du futur pour
lutter contre la copie 19
une peinture d'intérieur anti
bactérienne qui tue le virus en trois
minutes
elle nous vient de bretagne reportage
dans un instant de tvr à rennes pour
soutenir les producteurs à la proche des
fêtes le monde agricole lance
l'opération manger français nous irons
dans les vosges pour en connaître tous
les détails les saveurs miam miam
et puis noël approche à grands pas et si
vous donniez une seconde vie aux jouets
de vos enfants
la corse a mis en place la bourse aux
jouets et ça cartonne
enfin nous nous rendre en fin de journal
pour des images exceptionnelles à monaco
où un hélicoptère est intervenue il y a
quelques jours et ce pour des besoins de
travaux de consolidation d'une falaise
vous verrez c'est très spectaculaire on
commence donc ce journal avec cette
nouvelle qui pourrait être un peu
exceptionnel peut-être larmes du futur
pour venir à bout de lakovic 19 son nom
eut mana et elle nous vient de bretagne
c'est une peinture de revêtements
intérieurs anti bactérienne qui a été
testé contre le coronavirus et les
résultats sont tombés
90% du virus serait détruit en trois
minutes un peu comme le gel
hydroalcoolique que nous mettons sur nos
mains direction les côtes d'armor pour
tous les détails avec nos partenaires de
tvr sur place à rennes
avec son siège social installé à saint
pern en ille et vilaine et ses ateliers
à plouasne dans les côtes d'armor la
société armor habitat distribuer en
france depuis onze ans une peinture de
revêtements intérieurs antibactérienne
fabriqués en italie à l'aune du comique
19 le produit a été testé en laboratoire
en y déposant la souche du coronavirus
le résultat est tombé au mois d'octobre
le laboratoire en fait indique dans les
trois premières minutes 90 % de l'adn du
virus est détruit et dans les 15
premières minutes 100% de l'adn et
détruit donc il ne reste plus rien au
bout de 15 minutes
ce qui veut dire que l'on a un effet
actif très important et que l'on à
l'identique des gels hydro-alcooliques
on peut dire que l'on est là dans une
réduction de la transmission du virus
par loi de contacts dans tous les lieux
publics dans tout les salles d'attenté
des médecins ou des professions
libérales dans les hôpitaux les ehpad
les écoles les crèches bien évidemment
cette peinture peut avoir un effet très
intéressant sur la propagation du virus
pour obtenir de tels résultats le
principe actif de cette peinture
intitulé human à est protégé par un
brevet qui intègre des nanomatériaux
infiniment petit les produits actifs
contenus dans la peinture qui vont tuer
effectivement ces virus sont issus d'une
réaction avec des matières qui sont
plutôt des matières minérales qui vont
réagir avec la lumière donc la lumière
ces sont des produits ce qu'on appelle
photocatalytiques un petit peu comme
certains composants électroniques
aujourd'hui peuvent réagir en produisant
de l'électricité avec de la lumière
comme les panneaux photovoltaïques
désormais doté de l'étiquette antique
vide du mana est en vente à destination
des professionnels depuis trois semaines
la société armor habitat et son enseigne
arnaud 10 à l'exclusivité de sa
distribution sur le marché français
direction les yvelines maintenant dans
ce grand jt des territoires où les tests
de dépistage de lakovic 19 s'intensifie
ces derniers jours à lapproche bien sûr
des fêtes de fin d'année des initiatives
qui se multiplient pour répondre à la
demande dans les grandes villes mais
aussi dans les communes plus rurales
opéré en yvelines
dans le sud du département une mini
maison accueille les habitants avant de
partir prochainement vers d'autres
villages du département
c'est un reportage signé des équipes de
tv 78 sur place dans les yvelines donc
une taille ni house lieux insolites dans
lequel la mairie du perray-en-yvelines a
installé un centre de dépistage du coït
19 mobile
cet équipement va parcourir pendant un
mois minimum c'est ce communes de
l'agglomération rambouillet territoire
et bien les gens vont souvent à trappes
ou parfois vont à rambouillet où il ya
de la tente
donc on a décidé nous mêmes de mettre en
place notre dispositif qui est assez
unique s'est adapté particulièrement à
la ruralité où personne aucune de nos
communes n'aurions pu avoir ce propre
centre de test si nous ne l'avions pas
eu ni nos forces c'est tania housse
prend ses quartiers les mercredi et
samedi sur la place de la mairie du
perray en yvelines
ce jour là il n'y avait presque que des
habitants de la commune qui sont venus
effectuer un test pcr
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était une très
bonne initiative c'était très
intéressant de permettre plusieurs fois
par semaine au jour de la commune de
pouvoir venir se faire tester si
agréable spacieux aéré et puis les gens
sont super sympas aussi ce centre de
dépistage était aussi l'occasion de
sortir cette taille ni house qui dormait
sur un parking
depuis deux ans et acheté 30 mille euros
par la précédente municipalité
ça va quoi ça donne envie d'attendre
en lien avec le prestataire loxam end
deux aides soignantes ont la charge de
réaliser les tests mois avant que
j'arrive je doutais un peu
je savais pas ce que c'était dangereux
jamais fait dans ce genre d'endroit et
finalement c'est bien pratique environ
100 tests sont réalisés par jour un
dispositif faciliter aussi grâce aux
subventions de la région ile de france
un slogan vaut mieux souvent que toutes
les déclarations vos assiettes sont vos
emplois eh bien c'est ce slogan que
lance la filière agricole pour venir en
aide au secteur des producteurs durement
impactées par la fermeture des
restaurants vous le savez durant cette
crise sanitaire
alors pour écouler les stocks toutes les
astuces sont bonnes vous allez le voir
dans ce reportage dans une ferme de la
plaine des vosges à sous l'os sous
sainte et lov avec les équipes de
viavoice sur place regardez moi j'aime
le saumon fumé pilote bud escargots
huîtres crevettes dingue canard une
épaule de biche ou un truc comme ça une
bonne viande aux faux rythme annuel
voici un petit échantillon des mets qui
seront servis sur nos tables en fin
d'année reste à connaître la provenance
les chambres d'agriculture et les
syndicats agricoles gia et fnsea insiste
sur l'importance du consommer français
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire et
économique
le message c'est celui là un peu dur on
va dire du patriotisme gastronomique
notre agriculture vosgienne bien que
extrêmement riche et extrêmement variés
n'a pas tous les produits qui pourront
servir à la table la table de noël
donc effectivement le message est on
consomme local on consomme français le
département des vosges est leader
régional en termes d'industries
agroalimentaires employant 4 l'huile
salariés
les 167 ferme du territoire font
travailler plus de 3000 personnes
ainsi nos assiettes sont nos emplois et
période compliquée où les réseaux de
distribution soit un peu modifié parce
que on pourrait dire tout le monde
continue à manger mais il ya plus de
restauration où pratiquement plus donc
c'est important que
les consommateurs dans leurs gestes
citoyens d'achat fasse attention à soi
vigilants à acheter des produits de
l'industrie agroalimentaire française et
qui sont produits sur nos territoires
l'annulation des marchés de noël les
fêtes qui se feront en petit comité font
craindre une chute du chiffre d'affaires
ici au gaec de la grosse roche à sous
l'os sous sainte et loft près de neuf
châteaux les gérants ont compris
l'importance de diversifier leurs
débouchés
depuis deux mois il organise visite à la
ferme et vente sur place de la
coopérative qui venaient le chercher nos
clés pas qu'il vient toujours forcément
notre viande etc
et du coup de fer transformée pour le
vendre en direct au consommateur local
ont trouvé ça intéressant
la vente directe représente pour ce gars
est que moins de 2% du chiffre
d'affaires mais ce changement de réseau
de distribution tend à s'accentuer la
plateforme l'okapi qui regroupe les
producteurs vosgien le développement des
drive fermiers et plus largement celui
des réseaux de vente en circuits courts
en sont l'illustration
nous le savons tous ses courses de noël
sont souvent un tracas mais si vous
cherchez bien vous trouverez tout de
même dans vos régions quelques marchés
de noël ouvert oublier les marchés géant
bien sûr place à des places plus
modestes aux mesures sanitaires très
strictes souvent d'ailleurs
nous partons ce coup-ci à limoges qui
propose une sélection de produits
régionaux
regardez ce reportage de 7 à limoges
nos confrères sur place
à pied en voiture voire en navettes
électriques gratuites tous les moyens
sont bons pour rejoindre à la place de
la république
les artisans et producteurs du marché de
noël organisé par la chambre de métiers
la chambre d'agriculture avec l'aide du
département et de la ville de limoges
qui suit ses amis stars tisane créatrice
donc je fabrique en faïence des objets
très coloré très ludique
puis aussi on met une âme derrière la
personne qui l'a fabriqué rencontre la
personne on peut expliquer comment on
travaille marché où le port du masque
est bien respectée par les exposants et
chalon tous les jours et on essaie de ne
pas trop côtoyé quand il ya du monde
regardez ces aides l'existence miens
limoges oblige les arts du feu sont bien
présents céramiste et mayer et
porcelainier tiennent leur place
les métiers de bouche et les producteurs
sont également présents on peut même
trouver de quoi se remonter le moral la
dizaine de décibels et dans le petit
coffret avec ses beaux pétales de roses
gallica trop franche porta dans le
jardin en plein été pour moi miel c'est
particulier aussi
trop la praline et noix miel citron
meringuée voilà c'est ça c'est les
gourmandes mais après il ya des plus
classiques comme t'es pas les pisse
fleur de lin fleur d'oranger bon
j'imagine que ça fait du bien de sortir
de l'atelier de voir du monde
tout à fait les restaurateurs riverains
de la place est encore fermé font une
percée sur leur terrasse sans objectif
de rentabilité parce que je pense que
c'est plus un investissement d'autres
choses c'est bien pour le moral de tous
les gens qui sont là les équipes content
d'être ici mais voilà ils sentent un peu
à l'abandon
ce marché est ouvert tous les jours
attention le 24 décembre il fermera à 15
heures avec les fêtes qui approchent
bien sûr les initiatives solidaires font
chaud au coeur
elles font beaucoup de bien et exemple à
beaumont sur sarthe ce pompiste qui
s'est reconverti en livreur sa station
essence à vue bien sûr une forte baisse
de fréquentation avec le confinement il
a donc proposé à son directeur de livrer
à domicile et gratuitement toutes les
personnes qui ne pouvaient pas se
déplacer ou qui étaient en situation
d'isolement
un service qui a été très vite très
populaire et qui rencontre est très vite
son public
son portrait le portrait de ce livre
heures avec les équipes de lmtv sartre
sur place le confinement il a un peu
changé la vie de christophe ce pompiste
s'est retrouvé du jour au lendemain sans
client alors il s'est reconverti au sein
de son entreprise
il livre les courses à domicile et
gratuitement pour les personnes isolées
et n'a plus beaucoup de livres de
magasins qui livrent moyenne à quelques
je pense que tous les magasins livre met
en campagne je pense qu'on a
besoin autant qu'en ville c'est heureux
sont contents un service mais aussi un
lien social pour ses habitants qui
vivent en milieu rural ou dans certaines
maisons je vois en vraiment en campagne
le temps que je le temps que je décharge
donc j'ai charge avec le monsieur me
regarder puis bal adam et prépare la
petite tasse de café comprend tous les
trois ils sont contents ça je passe dix
minutes avec eux et puis un peu comme
les post ils font sûrement aussi pompier
il a mêlé les grands cartonné bascule
pour marquer mes rendez-vous à bas avec
ça il est grand comme ça le prochain
coup le magasin a rapidement trouvé sa
clientèle pour ce service
oh c'est génial je l' ai appris parce
que mon fils va régulièrement à super u
il a vu une grande affiche et m'a dit
maman parce qu'avant je faisais le craj
il m'a dit maman regarde ça c'est génial
un vieux nickels et la livraison à
domicile ne s'arrêtera pas aux dés
confinement christophe compte continuer
de livrer les clients qui en ont besoin
et faire perdurer le système
bonjour georg fischer merci d'être
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires en
duplex de tours vous avez écrit un livre
et c'est pour ça vous êtes avec nous
aujourd'hui chez food édition ce livre
s'appelle sans marque culte label france
et bien c'est l'histoire de l'apéritif
du bonnet ou des cachous lajaunie ou
bien des deux chevaux ou bien du be bop
ou du minitel toutes ces marques qui ont
fait la france avec souvent une certaine
nostalgie
alors pourquoi cette idée de livre
comment cela vous est-il venu guy
fischer ont fait l'idée de ce livre
c'était de rendre hommage en fait aux
savoir-faire français ou qui depuis
1850 ont inventé des marques absolument
géniale du canot pneumatique zodiac à la
4l renault
voilà c'était un petit peu un hommage au
savoir-faire français cyril au fond guy
fischer il s'agit du made in france
avant que ce soit à la mode
alors effectivement levés diniz qui
revenu en grâce avec le loto vide et la
crise sanitaire
ces marques que montre bien que le
concept existe depuis depuis des
décennies alors on le voit dans ce livre
des marques ont totalement disparu et
puis d'autres sont toujours bien vivace
comment vous expliquez que certaines
sont encore présents dans notre
quotidien et d'autre et bien on ne les
voit plus du tout une marque pour
qu'elle soit résilient dès qu'elle reste
elle doit réussir à passer l'air du
temps alors cette fois en termes de
design ce soit en terme de technique
pour passer les siècles
il doit y avoir également la qualité de
la marque la remise en cause le
renouvellement est celle qui
effectivement ont disparu souvent elles
ont été victimes un petit peu pas
d'arcalis mais on va en tout cas
d'immobilisme
merci guillaume fischer je rappelle que
vous avez écrit ce livre avec raphaël
turcat rédacteur en chef notamment dû
magazine technikart qui est votre co
auteur pour ce livre sans marque culte
label france chez les éditions food food
édition un excellent cadeau par ailleurs
pour les fêtes
merci beaucoup cyril nous partons dans
le sud-ouest à présent avec cette
initiative pour relancer le pouvoir
d'achat et les commerces de proximité
des habitants de sa commune le maire
d'ille sur têt en occitanie a débloqué
cent mille euros pour des bons d'achat
des chèques solidaire à destination de
tous les habitants peu importe les
revenus il suffit juste de remplir un
formulaire
les détails avec les équipes sur place
de vie occitanie
un parent à tour de rôle ses habitants
d'ille sur têt dans les
pyrénées-orientales viennent récupérer
des bons d'achat entre 20 et 80 euros
selon le foyer ces bons sont à dépenser
dans les petits commerces de la commune
une initiative du maire pour soutenir
l'économie locale en temps de crise
c'est tout le monde en fait d'un pouvoir
remonter la pente
franchement c'est super quoi c'est bien
la première fois que je pense que c'est
avec le pot vide et franchement on peut
dire merci
un coup de pouce également très apprécié
des commerces de proximité qui ont
beaucoup souffert des deux confinement
c'est hyper important de se sentir
soutenus par notre municipalité et ça
permet encore de rappeler justement à
tous les consommateurs locaux que nous
sommes présents que nous avons ré ouvert
nos portes et qu'on attend plus qu'on
est prêt à les accueillir
au delà des délais commerce le maire dit
sur têt veut aussi faire un geste pour
ses administrés
al'approche de noël badi on leur faire
un cadeau de noël mais aussi leur
pouvoir d'achat augmenter un peu pour
qu'ils puissent aussi consommé dans ces
commerces là au total la mairie a
débloqué cent mille euros pour ces bons
d'achat
c'est dans l'actualité mais c'est
également une controverse le président
de la république
emmanuel macron a annoncé cette semaine
un référendum pour inscrire le climat
dans la constitution vous en avez bien
sûr tous entendu parler dans nos régions
le combat pour l'environnement a déjà
commencé comme c'est le cas vous allez
voir dans les côtes d'armor ou un
groupement de gendarmerie a créé une
cellule contre les atteintes à
l'environnement
une première en france d'ailleurs deux
gendarmes se partage entre l'avait
numérique et le terrain les équipes de
la chaîne tébéo en bretagne les ombres
contraire regardez ça qu'ils ont vendu
ces deux gendarmes costarmoricains
traque les ventes d'espèce protégée
depuis le mois de septembre
il constitue la cellule contre les
atteintes à l'environnement
une première en france demain nous
allons sur dix n'ont récupéré un
crocodile tuera c'est qu'ils étaient
invente donc ça c'est ce qu'on va
rechercher principalement éviter que des
animaux qui sont protégés ou des
produits qui sont interdits se
retrouvent en toute publicité sur sur
les sites de vente en ligne et par me
les produits interdits ces gendarmes
sont particulièrement attentifs aux
produits phytosanitaires
c'est bidon à usage professionnel ont
été trouvés en vente sur leboncoin par
un particulier
il avait eu vent qu'on avait il y avait
possibilité de la ceni se reproduit sur
internet il ya tout simplement taper le
nom de la coopérative sur internet il
tout simplement à jeter des regards des
trois ans sans les utiliser
parce que son épouse ne voulais pas
qu'ils les utilisent et au bout 3 ans vu
que ça quand même coûte un certain prix
je crois de mémoire ça doit être 180
euros le bilan bc dijon leur vendre le
particulier a été convoqué en justice et
pour la coopérative la manche ce sont
des amendes la plupart du temps qui
peuvent se chiffrer en millions d'euros
cette cellule a vu le jour suite à la
demande de la tude ans mathias choqué la
multiplicité des atteintes à
l'environnement et les procédures qui
ont été dressés ont fait que je trouve
est nécessaire et utile de pouvoir me
consacrer entièrement à cette
problématique
à ce jour cette cellule a engagé une
quarantaine de procédures judiciaires
elle pourrait à l'avenir être créés dans
d'autres départements
la gendarmerie d'ile-de-france a déjà
contacté ces deux gendarmes pour se
renseigner sur cette initiative
voilà place à la rubrique écorégions
dans ce dont j'étais des territoires
vous avez l'habitude maintenant de
retrouver michel picaud chaque semaine
vous nous raconter l'histoire michel
très mouvementée d'une pme de la vienne
dont la marque de lingerie fine
s'appelle indiscrètes bon cyril bonjour
à toutes et à tous je voulais vous
parler aujourd'hui d'une pme spécialisée
dans la lingerie féminine résiliente est
exceptionnelle elle a été créée par
trois anciens hauts cadres licenciés
d'une célèbre marque qui avait fait le
choix de transférer sa production en
tunisie
fermant ainsi ces ateliers en france les
trois cadres décide alors nous sommes en
2010 de créer leur propre atelier leur
propre marque indiscrètes
la pme parvient à produire de la
lingerie en france à chauvigny dans la
vienne
mais en 2018 un gros client dépose son
bilan laisse une lourde ardoise et un
autre ne paye pas et ainsi de suite la
pme est endetté mars 2020 changement de
programme
les vingt trois couturières se
mobilisent cette fois ci pour
confectionner des masques de protection
mais il ya du stock de lingerie dans
l'entreprise et en février dernier
cambriolage tout disparaît ou presque
nouveau coup dur mais l'équipe reste
très uni et a su faire face
les projets aujourd'hui continue surtout
se concrétise une histoire de résilience
exceptionnelle la pugnacité et la gnac
sont toujours payante
voilà merci michel picaud un exemple
donc d'audace de courage et de
résilience dans ce grand jt des
territoires nous partons maintenant pour
la corse
cela s'appelle la bourse aux jouets à
calvi s'est tenue la première édition de
cette brocante enfantine et les équipes
de via telle est pas aisé était bien sûr
sur place aux côtés de nos charmants
bambins regardes et tu es très bien pesc
et comme ça ça permet de faire de
l'ordre dans ma chambre et il y en a
marre ranger qu'est ce que tu as fait
comme à faire toi aujourd'hui et beige
et vendu des livres surtout des livres
et un télescope un microscope
une loi est ce que tu en as tu d'autres
j'ai acheté ces castes oreilles
c'est une très chouette initiative de
vendre les jouets deuxièmement des
livres on est tous dans le même bateau
les parents je pense aujourd'hui les
enfants ont beaucoup beaucoup de jouets
on a trop de choses et c'est bien de
vendre ce qu'ils on utilise pas que le
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait utiliser que
les choses continuent à vivre
on a bien vu qu'il ya des parents des
grands parents des enfants qui étaient
contents de dénicher un petit livre ont
un petit jouet une perruche en jeu au
final nous on est content de se
débarrasser et eux sont ravis d'avoir un
petit jouet à 56 - euros ou 2 euros
bientôt c'est noël je pense plusieurs
personnes ont retrouvé des petits
cadeaux pour cousin cousine et neveux
nièces petits-enfants c'est mignon
aujourd'hui c'est une bourse aux jouets
chose qui n'a jamais eu lieu auparavant
les gens vendent échanges entre des
enfants dans des échanges entre une
seconde vie des jouets c'est un
recyclage donc les gens achètent à petit
prix peuvent offrir et hélas tout à
l'heure il ya une dame qui a acheté
beaucoup de jouer je pense qu'elle va
faire plaisir à beaucoup de petits
enfants le but c'est de mettre au point
des rencontres intergénérationnelles
c'est un endroit qui est mis à
disposition des exposants gratuitement
par la mairie de calvi c'est une
initiative du ccas quelques commerces
font l'effort d'être ouvert donc voilà
ça redynamiser un petit peu le centre de
khalis c'est une première mais je pense
que ce sera à renouveler tous les ans
vous avez vu dans les titres tout à
l'heure ses images très spectaculaires
elles nous viennent de monaco alors
prenons de la hauteur direction la tête
de chien à la turbie où un hélicoptère
est intervenue il ya quelques jours et
ce pour les besoins de travaux de
consolidation d'une falaise à proximité
ce sont des images de nos confrères sur
place de monaco info
un reportage de sandrine et
d'alexandra paolini et nous sommes à
quelques pas de l'observatoire situé à
la turbie ici le panorama est magnifique
une vue imprenable sur la principauté
c'est aussi l'endroit qui a été choisi
pour permettre à cet hélicoptère de se
poser une opération délicate
la participation de cet hélicoptère une
condition sine qua none
alors aujourd'hui ont été réalisées les
opérations de délits portage pour
pouvoir amener le matériel nécessaire
donc aux travaux de réhabilitation des
comportements non des comportements
existants de la falaise du beau tu quand
on est actuellement sur la tête de chien
et une centaine de mètres en contrebas
on va trouver la falaise du bo tuant
donc falaise qui domine à la fois la
moyenne corniche et la sortie du tunnel
du tunnel rainier iii donc le tunnel qui
assure la liaison entre monaco et la
france dans le sens sortant une falaise
qui dans les années 90 a été équipée de
soixante deux ouvrages de confortement
pour prévenir les chutes de pierres et
maintenir ainsi la sécurité sur la
moyenne corniche et d'ici la fin de
l'année on va commencer à conforter
certains blocs c'est à dire on va fort
et on va poser des câbles efforts et les
rochers en profondeur pourrait enfiler
des bars qu'on appelle les des crayons
les boulons d'ancrage sont débarrassés
longue entre 4 5 mètres pour stabiliser
ces anciens ancrage qu'ils sont
maintenant trop vieux quattro anciens et
ensuite en janvier on va transporter un
autre compresseur beaucoup plus gros qui
va nous permettre avec une autre machine
qui est bien plus grosse que celle qu'on
m'a utilisé maintenant qui est
maintenant c'est un t21 ça s'appelle un
espèce de marteau piqueur mais auquel on
rallonge des tiges pour forer la roche
et tandis qu'en janvier on va voir un
autre une autre machine qui elle va
forer plus profond aussi et qui
permettra ainsi la pose de barde plus
gros dit à m nous suivrons d'ailleurs
cette étape afin de mesurer la dimension
acrobatique de ce type de travaux voilà
et puis je signale cette initiative de
nos confrères du courrier picard nos
partenaires du groupe rossel qui ont
organisé une table ronde le rendez-vous
des entrepreneurs avec la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie d'amiens
picardie
il proposait une conférence en ligne
durant laquelle il a été question du
soutien aux entreprises en cette période
de crise
il en est ressorti des propositions
concrètes et ambitieuses que vous pouvez
retrouver en ligne sur courrier picard
point fr vous verrez l'adresse internet
s'affiche sur cet écran ce rendez-vous
des entreprises et bien se maintiendra
l'année prochaine et continuera nous
vous signalons d'ailleurs les nouvelles
initiatives qui auront lieu avec la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
d'amiens picardie
voilà merci d'avoir suivi le grand jt
des territoires on se retrouve pour une
prochaine édition sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales mais aussi sur tv5
monde
au revoir à tous et à très vite pour une
nouvelle édition
[Musique]